THANKS.
>> WHATEVER HAPPENS AT THE
SUMMIT HERE IN SINGAPORE, IT
WILL HAVE MAJOR RAMIFICATIONS
FOR THE REST OF THE WORLD IN
GENERAL.
FOR THE ASIAN-PACIFIC REGION, IN
PARTICULAR.
WITH THAT STORY TONIGHT, FROM
SEOUL SOUTH KOREA, HERE'S SENIOR
FOREIGN AFFAIRS CORRESPONDENT
GREG PALKOT.
>> NO ONE'S LOOKING CLOSER AT
WHAT'S HAPPENING AT THE
SINGAPORE TRUMP KIM SUMMIT THAN
THOSE ON THE KOREAN PENINSULA
AND REGION.
MOST DIRECTLY AFFECTED BY
TENSIONS THAT HAVE SET THE AREA
TO THE BRINK OF NUCLEAR WAR.
NORTH KOREANS HAVE BEEN
LIVING -- SOUTH KOREANS HAVE
BEEN LIVING IN THE SHADOW OF
NORTH KOREA'S THREAT FOR YEARS.
THE REASON WHY SOUTH KOREAN
PRESIDENT MOON JAE IN TOOK THE
DIPLOMATIC LEAD WITH TWO SUMMITS
WITH KIM.
THE LOCALS HOWEVER HAVE BEEN
THROUGH PEACE MOVES BEFORE.
>> IT'S NOT A SENSE OF
DELUSIONAL HOPE HERE BUT THERE'S
CAUTIOUS OPTISM THAT WE ARE
SEE -- OPTIMISM THAT WE ARE
SEEING DEVELOPMENTS.
>> ALSO MENTIONED AT LAST WEEK'S
WHITE HOUSE SUMMIT WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP, JAPANESE PRIME
MINISTER ABE'S CONCERN ABOUT
HUMANITARIAN ISSUES ESPECIALLY
JAPANESE CITIZENS WHO HAVE BEEN
KIDNAPPED BY NORTH KOREA.
>> Translator: I HAVE EXPLAINED
THE ABDUCTION ISSUE AGAIN AND
CONVEYED TO HIM THE EARNEST WISH
OF THE FAMILIES OF THE
ABDUCTEES.
>> BOTH COUNTRIES INTEREST WILL
BE TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT IN
SINGAPORE ACCORDING TO SECRETARY
OF STATE POMPEO.
>> THERE'S NO DAYLIGHT BETWEEN
THE SOUTH KOREANS, THE JAPANESE
AND THE UNITED STATES WITH
RESPECT TO OUR APPROACH.
TO HOW WE RESOLVE THIS ISSUE
WITH RESPECT TO NORTH KOREA.
>> AS FOR NORTH KOREAN CITIZENS,
THEY REPORTEDLY DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHEN OR WHERE THE SUMMIT IS
HAPPENING.
JUST THAT THEIR LEADER WILL BE
MEETING WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
ANALYSTS SAY HE CARES LESS ABOUT
THEM, MORE ABOUT GETTING
RESPECT.
>> HAVING HIGH LEVEL MEETINGS,
THEY CAN BUILD A NARRATIVE
AROUND THAT AND PORTRAY THE
LEADER AS AN EQUAL TO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> ALL SIDES ARE LOOKING ALSO AT
WHETHER THERE AT LEAST COULD BE
SOME MOVEMENT AT THIS MEETING
TOWARDS THE DECLARING OF AN END
TO THE KOREAN WAR.
THAT CONFLICT WAS HALTED WITH A
TRUCE SOME 65 YEARS AGO.
THAT INDEED WOULD BE A PEACE
DIVIDEND FROM THE SINGAPORE